on va faire l'interview par amour
à la louche pas pendant le génial c'est
bien je peux bouger la main par amour
est ce que vous seriez prêt à arrêter de
jouer de la guitare par amour pour vous
et pour moi oui mais par exemple pour
nom mais alors si ça lui plaît le plus
bien pas un mot est ce que vous seriez
prêt à cacher le corps de quelqu'un que
je viens de tuer au nom oui sans
problème
enfin c'est rien est ce que vous seriez
prêt par amour arrêter de fumer
dur dur là il faut aimer là on peut pas
fumer en plus la stratégie n'a plus
droit de fumer avant pour les fumées du
temps de lunettes noires en fumée donc
c'est bien par amour ouais c'est pas
trop mon sens bien car il est prêt à
arrêter dessus d'amour par amour est-ce
que vous accepteriez qu'elle est un
amant quand on aime les gens n'ont envie
qu'il soit heureux ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont pas rameaux à ce monsieur je vous
seriez prêt à accepter que j'ai une
maîtresse ouais c'est par amour on est
prêt à tout on est prêt à tout quand on
a tout par amour est ce que vous seriez
prêt à vivre avec ma maîtresse et moi
tous les froids est ce qu'elle est s'il
ya une chatte dans l'histoire et vous
qu'un ça c'est pas un terreau du
châtelet est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez que votre jules et une
maîtresse je crois pas non plus mais pas
là mais si je sais pas moi même les gens
ont envie qu'il soit heureux mais je
fais tout pour qu'il soit heureux
pardon madame je sais tout pour qu'il
soit heureux oui j'ai pas jusque là mais
vous me mit j'ai toujours accepté qu'il
y ait des femmes donc
ça fait bizarre mais c'est bien comme ça
vous n'avez pas tout le temps sur la
route et pas toujours sur le dos et nuit
par amour ou est ce que vous seriez
prête à vivre à trois avec le mec est là
maintenant et vous non plus ah non nizar
sassi d'âge
pas un mot coma si votre maîtresse
moi si j'étais votre allemand mais peu
importe est ce que vous seriez prêt à
aller tous les samedis dans un club
échangiste
ouais si je peux boire un coup ou tant
que si la femme a demandé que j'y vais
tout de suite demandé c'est pas une
danoise une dérive cantine est ce que
vous seriez prêt alors je vais dire moi
puisque apparemment est quelque chose
qui sera connu ce soir par amour est ce
que vous seriez prêt à devenir mon
esclave sexuelle votre esclave sexuelle
tout ce que je vous demande pas de la
sexualité tout bien laurent baffie au
ciné dont il est le droit mais
maintenant il est pas très branché sexe
mais non et vous par exemple votre votre
jules vous dis voilà si tu m'aimes tu
deviens mon esclave sexuelle à 6 à votre
programme c'est des services sexuels
je me demande si on va voter pour un jeu
compliqué le conseil national
interrégional les verts n'ont consulté
pas conseil national se passe après une
semaine de négociations courant et où on
n'y arrivera jamais par amour est ce que
vous prendriez du viagra concernés si
oui par qui on a dans les bois sont ici
paris on est remonté mois ci en plus
j'en prends il va t il y va mourir par
amour est ce que vous seriez prêt à vous
refaire faire le sexe comme je joue de
la guitare avec mon sexe ou bjelica
partout quand ils scratch avec 116